on place le personnage au milieu de ce
ring briques de caméras vous voyez
quatre caméras positionnées autour de
personnages à 360 degrés pour qu'on
puisse avoir
l'entièreté du personnage né il ya trois
ans le projet au lou cap 3d menée par le
studio french touch factory propose des
prix accessibles pour la capture
volumétrique vidéo les publics visés par
ces hologrammes 3d l'univers du jeu
vidéo mais aussi la médecine et la
formation on pourra dans une scène avec
en réalité virtuelle et augmentée ou
directement sur son ordinateur ou sa
tablette tourner autour du personnage en
mouvement s'approcher des gestes et voir
précisément ces gestes en 3d le
quatrième mine paris reasearch day se
tenait au domaine de madame elisabeth à
versailles le 5 juillet une première
dans les yvelines pour marquer le
partenariat entre le département et
l'école des mines de paris en 2024
l'établissement aura son campus sur le
plateau de versailles satory pour
relever ces formidables défis du 21e
siècle au premier rang desquels la
transition vers un monde durable en
essayant de limiter le réchauffement
climatique à un degré 5 on a besoin
d'innovation ces grands changements ils
n'auront lieu que si effectivement nous
avons des talents pour le conduire
depuis l'intérieur de l'entreprise et
c'est ce à quoi nous efforçons en tant
que grande école de former des
ingénieurs légalement des docteurs des
scientifiques l'école des mines c'est ça
sera anniv line un porte-drapeau très
important de l'excellence illinoise pour
la recherche quinze projets étaient
présentés autour de l'industrie du futur
la mobilité l'intelligence artificielle
ou encore l'écologie celui du centre de
mise en forme des matériaux
s'intéressait à la recyclabilité du
plastique pet et dans des bouteilles
l'étude porte sur le comportement de ce
plastique recyclé lorsqu'il est mélangé
à du pays hôte et vierge ces matériaux
et doivent recevoir de grand niveau de
déformation au cours d'un procédé de
soufflage de bouteilles est donc où on
va pouvoir comparer les différences de
comportement aux grandes déformations
entre des matériaux vierge est des
matériaux recyclés plus de 200
participants sont venus célébrer et
valoriser ses projets scientifiques lors
de ce mini paris ri sortie des